le sud de la colombie britannique une
région idyllique maintenant dévastée
voici ce que des flammes ont laissé sur
leur passage
un triste mélange de cendres et de
structures carbonisés des ruines voilà
tout ce qu'il reste d'une trentaine de
résidences de la région est un art on a
perdu sa maison
il a pu se rendre sur les lieux pour
constater l'étendue des dommages réu des
choses laides c'est pas beau c'est des
maisons qui sont tombés à terre la tête
brûlée des arbres les pâtes aux côtés de
le rester c'est de tomber et je sais pas
vous battre et les deux ans cette moto
est à peu près tout ce qui lui reste
on n'a plus rien on a tout perdu nos
maisons sont à faire tout est à faire
on n'a plus rien d'autre comme cette
femme ont été plus chanceux
les flammes se sont dangereusement
rapproché de sa maison vendredi sa
piscine s'est avéré être une arme de
taille contre le feu les pompiers ont
utilisé l'eau pour protéger cette maison
et celle de voisins
même si les pompiers font du progrès la
situation demeure critique et le temps
est toujours très chaud et sec pour
éviter que des scènes comme celle ci se
multiplient dans la province les
autorités demandent aux britanno
colombien d'être prudent surtout que
même si une enquête est toujours en
cours tout porte à croire que le feu de
rock creek a été causée par des
activités humaines
les citoyens sont aussi appelé à faire
des dons en question d'aider ceux qui
devront être relogés pendant qu'ils
reconstruisent leur maison de campagne
de financement a été lancée dans les
dispensaires d'alcool de la province une
manière d'encourager les gens qui
profitent de leurs vacances à penser à
ceux pour qui cet été est très difficile
si raphaël bovio claire radio canada
rock creek